more for experience my one you won't
defend there's one class I would not
defend on its face which would be
terrorists ooh I I can't say that I've
been look I've only been doing criminal
defense for about a year so I have not
personally been approached yeah you're
still nine bags bro once you get to the
big stuff yeah I can't say that that
well I can't say that terrorism what's
it right I'm from New York I lived
through 9/11 you know I've seen that and
I just don't it'd be very tough to stand
by by you know someone that commits an
act of terrorism but look even for those
there's a case there's a case I mean
there's two sides every story for the
corn chief or everyone that's quarantine
I think it's on HBO still there's a
documentary it's called the Newburgh
four or something along those lines okay
and the FBI got some sort of hunch that
these guys in upstate New York not too
far from New York City were involved in
terrorism and they were planning a plot
in New York City and they set up a sting
operation they set up an undercover to
go up there and kind of befriend these
four guys you know to learn about them a
little bit and these guys had guns and a
few other things but they weren't
criminals they didn't I don't think
they've never committed a crime before
and there was not much by way of a plan
to actually commit any sort of crime of
terrorism but the FBI was so you know
engaged by this whole set they had that
they sent this guy up there and he did
and this is what the the documentary is
about is he really entrapped them
it's called entrapment yeah into going
through with this plan that they never
really had plans to go through and I
think they were convicted and then they
got out on an appeal but it showed that
they had no reason or or plan to commit
this crime until the FBI agent got there
befriended them and said look I got
these bombs in my basement right
thinking about targeting this area are
you guys in for the
you know we need to pursue you know this
cause whatever maybe and he kind of
brainwashed and trapped them so he
radicalized them he radicalized them and
interesting and that it just goes to
show that you know the people at trial
the jury that heard that case they
probably didn't see that and now the
documentary sheds light on it you know
or the attorney didn't do a good enough
job of showing that that's what happened
it's a tough time the case that I would
defend it looks like terrorism but it's
really not I mean he radicalized in the
whole way yeah so that's a good example
that tied and I know that that
documentary about the Newburgh case was
pretty spot-on but look in general
terrorism would be pretty tough to to
stand next to and defend but there's a
lot of good defense attorneys that do it
I mean a lot of people just want to make
sure that a person gets a fair trial
they get a fair disposition a lot of it
has to do with death penalty which is
more of a philosophical approach I mean
there's there's death penalty attorneys
that just take on those cases just
because as a matter who it is it doesn't
matter who it is the Boston Marathon
bomber Oklahoma City bomber it doesn't
matter who they are they could they
always say their first line those
defense attorneys at trial they say he
did it they say I'm not denying one
thing he did it he set off this bomb he
goes all I wanted to talk about with you
is why he shouldn't be given the death
penalty okay